oh attends mon pote on a compris
oh-oh-oh-oh ne comprends pas - Peter tu es
nu censé être à mon mariage en ce
moment
essayant juste de ne pas regarder ton
G Oh Benny hé oh tu inventes les gens
tu dois accepter le fait qu'il
ne vient pas il sera là à moins que tu
ne sois arrêté pour ce que je ne suis pas un streaker
j'essaie juste d'obtenir  à ma
mère de mariage j'ai besoin de votre aide en
train de paniquer je suis nu Oh 20 blocs
nous sommes vieux maintenant et je continue de répéter le
même pouvoir encore et encore belle et
parfaite prise de conscience regarder en arrière
quand vous en trouvez sur la piste que vous
Je peux crier sur toi ivre alors je vais te montrer ce que nous dansons oh oh
et pose tu penses que la vieille dame va
comme ça Je pense qu'elle irait lui botter le cul
où es-tu tu es d'accord je viens
pour  toi et quel monde t'a-t-elle choisi
plutôt que moi c'est ce que tu apportes à
la table maintenant cette femme mérite un
excellent moyen je suis désolé qu'elle ait juste besoin d'être
retirée à l'arrière o  h Je vais le
botter dans le dos J'ai besoin d'emprunter
monsieur Je ne te donne pas mon perron
tu vas me [ __ ] le bordel oh ouais
[Applaudissements]
ouais Devon vas-y
[Musique]